i think my smartest business decision
has been
going for it like having no fear and
just
even if they failed and even if it
hasn't turned out the way that i wanted
to i've learned so much from it
kim kardashian is an entrepreneurial
force and
et's been with her every step of the way
while building her
empire hey e.t i'm kim kardashian and
welcome to my closet
from reality star the reason why i
really wanted to do a reality show was
because
there's so many different stereotypes of
what hollywood kids are like
to beauty and fashion mogul i like to
change up my look
all the time and now a proud momma of
four with legal aspirations
it's so important to give the perfect
amount of attention to every kid
and so especially with school now and
everything that i'm doing i really just
can't extend myself beyond this
even with all of that on her plate the
kim pyre keeps expanding
i like always being busy when i'm not
busy
that's when i start to get uncomfortable
2007 was a year that really got things
going for kim
when keeping up with the kardashians
premiered and rocketed her to fame
i just think that i i'm growing up a
little bit and i'm
you know hoping to just be a little bit
more sophisticated
kim was popping up everywhere even as a
scripted version of herself
on tv hits like how i met your mother
you made a brave step today
remember what shakespeare wrote virtue
is bold
and goodness never fearful i got a call
to um you know be a guest
star on the show and i was so excited
and so honored and i jumped at the
opportunity and here i
am a few hours later
that same year kim cha-cha her way onto
our screens on season seven of dancing
with the stars
this was something that was really new
for me and every dance was a huge
accomplishment for me and i'm just
so glad that i did it and i took that
risk because i never thought i'd do
anything like this before
and even as her hollywood dreams came
true kim kept her day job
running the dash boutiques alongside her
sisters courtney and chloe
i think that we know that having you
know our show on the air is a great
commercial
you know for us and for our brands and
you know before the show we loved
fashion we had a clothing store
and having the show has given us such a
great opportunity to expand our brand
kim's personal brand expanded with the
launch of her first product
a fragrance each fragrance that i've
worn in the past really
reminds me of really special memories
that i have so i wanted to take all of
my favorite memories
and put it into one bottle kim also made
her mark on social media becoming an
influencer before we even knew that term
she launched her own
iphone app made her own emojis and most
importantly
helped coin the term break the internet
i think you have to do whatever you're
comfortable with
clearly i'm comfortable posting you know
sexy bikini pics
but sometimes i'm not so it just depends
then came
kk beauty i wanted this whole kkw beauty
experience to just be larger than life
the brand quickly became kkw for west
and launched makeup sense and of course
kim's
shapewear line skims cementing the star
as a force to be reckoned with in the
world of e-commerce
my advice would be go for it
try what you can you know
and just work hard so like the decisions
just might not have panned out the way
that i wanted to but i think just
having that experience just taught me so
much about the business that i'm doing
now
but there's no business more important
to kim than family business
mom is her favorite job i am so busy
doing so many other things i want to
make sure
each kid gets so much of my attention i
think
four is the perfect magic number for me
who's most likely to turn into the
momager next
not me you think me i think as a mom
i can say yes to things that they really
want to do in the moment
and i think they're ready because they
ask me so many times but i think
i think i gotta like chill motherhood
seems to have inspired
kim's latest passion criminal justice
reform
she's soon to add lawyer to her
extensive resume
following in her late father robert
kardashian's footsteps
i'm really good focused on like beauty
fragrance skims
law school mom not necessarily in that
order
but that is more than enough for me